j'ai été entrepreneur
je ne le suis plus
je ne crie plus de start up
pour vous dire 11 je pense que les start
up c'est dépassé
je viens ici pour vous confier une
conviction
l'entreprise telle qu'on l'a connue est
en voie de disparition
startup incluse
je vous parlais de la suite
mais revenons un peu en arrière
qu'est ce que c'est au fond une
entreprise on l'a ceci très souvent à
l'économie de marché
en oubliant parfois qu'à l'intérieur
d'une entreprise il n'y a pas de marché
lorsqu'on vient le matin son travail on
ne cherche pas à vendre ses compétences
dans sa boîte
les interactions entre collaborateurs ne
sont pas d'ordre marchand leur prix
n'est pas sujet à négociation
la nature de l'entreprise
n'est pas de l'ordre du marché elle est
alors d'un dispositif juridique
le contrat de travail et la
subordination de l'employé assez large
en échange de contreparties matériel
d'une rémunération stable de la
protection contre les accidents de la
vie le travailleur salarié concède une
part de sa liberté
il ne décide ni du prix de ce qu'il
produit ni bien souvent du travail
qu'ils effectuent mais ça fonctionne
très bien
à la fin du xxème siècle près de 90% des
actifs étaient des employés des
travailleurs salariés
les économistes ont expliqué ce
phénomène et ce succès en montrant que
le marché comporter des coûts
dont l'entreprise est l'organisation
hiérarchique permettait de s'affranchir
lorsqu'un besoin survient
pas besoin d'aller chercher les
ressources qui nous manquent pas besoin
d'aller négocier le prix
contractualiser et déclencher des
procédures de règlement pour chaque
service rendu
il est tout simplement moins cher de
disposer d'une force de travail captive
les alors il faut se poser une question
si l'entreprise et l'organisation est
archi qu est tellement plus efficaces
que le marché
pourquoi y at il encore des marchés
pourquoi n'at-on pas vu au fil du temps
s'installer grossir des entreprises ou
une entreprise qui domine son marché
voir tous les marchés en absorbant ou en
écrasant tous ses concurrents
la réponse chacun la connaît
intuitivement
plus une organisation est archi grossit
et plus elle devient lourde - inde et
efficace
ses coûts de coordination interne
dépasse les avantages par rapport aux
coûts de transaction du marché
la bureaucratie s'installe les décisions
sont prises loin du terrain sont moins
pertinente la communication devient plus
compliqué
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya eu
tant d'innovations managériales
depuis l'organisation scientifique du
travail la standardisation des tâches
jusqu aux méthodes agiles
le l'aplatissement des niveaux
hiérarchiques
ou l'entreprise libéré
mais au 21ème siècle
ces améliorations changer d'échelle
certaines entreprises ont trouvé le truc
pour contourner le problème pour
résoudre l'équation accroissement de
l'activité
alourdissement de la structure
avec les plateformes les start up de
l'économie collaborative on a trouvé le
moyen de délégués à l'extérieur de la
structure le travail à faire avec les
facebook über le bon coin ce sont des
utilisateurs
des clients et partenaires des acteurs
non subordonnée à la hiérarchie qui
effectue une part du travail qui était
auparavant faites par les employés
et ça ça a permis de dégager une
efficacité économique redoutable et de
bouleverser au passage des secteurs
industriels entiers transports médias
commerce tourisme
mais
évidemment ces start-up de l'économie
collaborative et ces plateformes sont
des drôles de phénomènes d'un côté ils
satisfont nos besoins en nous mettant en
réseau d'une façon tellement performante
qu'on aurait du mal à se passer d'eux ou
d'elle aujourd'hui
d'un autre côté
derrière leurs marques sympathique et
leur application conviviale elle cache
bien souvent un visage plus sombres
moins reluisant
gouvernance opaque
hypercentralisé évasion fiscale
capacités de surveillance et une
manipulation colossal et puis un
comportement bien souvent prédateurs
vis-à-vis de ce réseau d'acteurs qui les
fait vivre
les intérêts de leurs actionnaires
ne sont pas toujours
le même que ceux de leurs utilisateurs
ou des citoyens en général
aujourd'hui les choses changent
parce qu'il est devenu impensable de se
passer des services de ses plateformes
et insupportable il sacrifier notre
souveraineté notre citoyenneté notre
autonomie
alors de nouveaux types d'organisations
émergent on les appelle d'art ou des aot
organisation décentralisée autonome
a de quoi s'agit-il qu'est ce que les
dao
et davos ont des organisations qui
fonctionne en utilisant des technologies
de la blood chaînes et des crypto actifs
c'est-à-dire une infrastructure
numérique public fonctionnant à l'aide
de milliers d'ordinateurs connectés en
réseaux indépendants les uns des autres
est capable de représenter des objets
numériques non duplicable c'est à dire
de la valeur
mais ce rentrer dans tous ses détails
techniques il ya trois choses
importantes pour comprendre ce phénomène
le premier l'autonomie ces technologies
permettent à des communautés ou des
collectifs d'individus de détenir
ensemble directement des actifs
financiers sans avoir à dépendre de
tiers de confiance qu'il s'agisse de
banque ou d'un pdg
deuxièmement la transparence il est
impossible de dissimuler les opérations
sur ces actifs ils sont visibles à tous
les participants sur le registre public
de la blood chaîne
troisièmement la décentralisation les
règles de fonctionnement de ces
organisations et en particulier de
manipulation de ses actifs financiers
sont elles-mêmes du logiciel placée
également sous le contrôle du collectif
avec la décentralisation la transparence
et l'autonomie pour la première fois des
communautés d collectif d'individus pas
ou très peu et hiérarchisé peuvent
accomplir des choses qui étaient
auparavant l'apanage d'entreprise
et on les voit ainsi apparaître et
croître et se multiplier dans des
secteurs comme la finance le gaming
l'édition de logiciels on les voit
poindre dans des secteurs comme le média
les médias la culture la politique
l'action humanitaire
demain nous les verrons se diffuser dans
tous les aspects de l'activité humaine
comme les plates-formes
cedaro ces organisations décentralisées
ont trouvé le truc aussi pour contourner
le problème accroissement de l'activité
égale
alourdissement de la structure elle
aussi elle laisse chacun participé
volontairement à leur activité mais à la
différence de ce qui se passe dans les
plateformes cette participation active
peut adresser absolument tous les
aspects de l'organisation y compris les
plus stratégiques
au lieu des actions et des parts
sociales
les dao utilise un instrument numérique
appelé le token jetons
ce token est un objet numérique
programmables et distribué non seulement
aux investisseurs ou aux cofondateurs
comme dans les start up classique mais
également
aux contributeurs que ce soit des
contributeurs d'un jour où des
contributeurs permanent aux
sympathisants aux utilisateurs aux
partenaires à d'autres daoud et on voit
ainsi apparaître une possibilité pour
toutes les parties prenantes d'un projet
d'influer sur le devenir de
l'organisation et de décider ensemble
de la manière d'utiliser la richesse
qu'elle crée
alors bien sûr il ya aussi des arnaques
et aussi des rêves creux il ya aussi du
marketing de start-up recyclé dans la
blue jays tout n'est pas rose au pays
des dao
mais il y a également d'autant type
projet on en a vu qui réunissait des
millions de dollars pour racheter
collectivement la copie originale de la
constitution américaine ou pour tenter
de faire libérer de julian assange
on en voit qui créent aujourd'hui des
produits financiers d'un ordre d'un type
nouveau qui sont accessibles à tous et à
chacun y compris aux personnes non
bancarisées
accessible de partout
on en voit qui réinvente le financement
des biens publics en transformant des
mécanismes de donation en investissement
et puis évidemment on en voit aussi qui
créé l'infrastructure numérique de
demain
en transformant la gestion des noms de
domaines la gestion du code source les
interfaces de programmation tous ses
composants indispensables à
l'infrastructure numérique en les
transformant des biens collectifs
on voit ressurgir avec les dao des
pratiques d'autogestion qu'on croyait
disparue révolu depuis le déclin de
l'idéologie socialiste
pas sous forme de discours mais dans les
actes
pas sous la forme de conflit de classe à
l'intérieur des entreprises mais au sein
de communautés hôtes au gouvernement
demain les écosystèmes que nous habitons
seront construits et co administré par
chacun d'entre nous selon des modalités
que les dao nous invite à explorer et à
créer merci